[Musique]
sur la question de l'accord de pêche
n'est pas respecté par les britanniques
ce qui m'inquiète aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement après onze mois le
gouvernement est entre autres l'union
européenne s'était décidé à mettre en
place des mesures de rétorsion face au
royaume uni parce que la situation ne
peut plus durer les pêcheurs n'ont pas
leur licence ne peuvent pas travailler
il ya même quelques entreprises de pêche
qui met la clé sous la porte la
situation et devient intenable
finalement ces mesures de rétorsion dont
je considérais qu'elle venait déjà très
tard puisque ça fait près de 11 mois
qu'on est sur ce sur cette question on
les a cueillies quand même avec une
certaine bienvenus
et puis 48 heures après bouleversement
le président de la république après un
échange qu'il a à rome avec les anglais
revient sur la table des négociations et
puis on est reparti pour des palabres
mais ces palabres pour les allume avant
le président on les a eus pendant le
break site et on les a eus après le
break site donc ça ne peut plus durer je
ne sais pas si aujourd'hui on peut
mettre toute la confiance envers
gouvernement du royaume uni sur cette
question donc il faut arrêter je le
pense la diplomatie a ses limites elle a
ses limites et elle a prouvé ces villes
onze mois c'est trop tôt les pêcheurs
souffle et il est temps d'agir c'est une
question de survie des entreprises
maritimes et dans certains territoires
d'une activité liée à la pêche qui est
très très important
[Musique]